du hast die frage ist was bin ich alle
selbst willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute heute mit max und mit der konzern
vor einiger zeit heute ein wer bin ich
rausgegangen
das hat sich mir gut gefallen während
genau deswegen kommt heute eine neue
folge zusammen mit den zwei obdachlosen
hier leute meine einzige hoffnung für
das heutige video ist dass man mir nicht
wieder durch die hose schauen kann und
so wie bei dem einen riegel im sommer
weg will denn das eintracht trier könnte
beschreiben sie als zehnte mit einem
youtuber draufkleben die dem jeweils
anderen auf den kopf und dann wird bloß
geraten und wer gewinnt darf h2o wird
wenn ich gewinnt muss einfach
verschenken weil sie die leute ja unsere
schüler max hat ein schild
januar ihr schild ich habe irgendetwas
hier sein gesicht hängen perfekt fangen
wir an du fängst an max ist okay los
geht bin ich ein mann
ich sage das aber sehr web nein nein
nein
du wirst wissen was habe ich über eine
million abonnenten wie vielleicht auch
infrage einen nehmen auch zwei abenden
frank hier habe ich über einen jungen
mit bin ich eine frau nein ich mache ich
bloß
ich bin ein mann habe ich dunkle habe
naja bin ich über 25 fünften schiff mach
ich jetzt place ich bin ein mann ja es
ist keine frage
da hat dann schnappt mache deutsche
videos ja da habe ich meinen kanal mein
gaming gemacht nein nein bin ich aus
deutschland ja mache ich
deutschsprachige videos habe ich mal
displays gemacht er kenne ich diese
person
er hat diese person über 500.000
abonnenten komme ich aus deutschland mit
bin ich gleich in eichstätt
dann habe ich über 10.000 abonnenten
haben bei einigen habe ich schon mal
minecraft videos gemacht
jetzt habe ich schon mal videos
gemachten denen ich mich gezeigt habe
dass weil sie das steht überhaupt nicht
also ich glaube nein bin ich aus dem
team tun nein und ich gerade in köln
habe ich bei minecraft wahl teilgenommen
könnte man so sagen da ich bei der
ersten staffel bei minecraft war dabei
habe ich neben meinem großen minecraft
projekt teilgenommen
solche übersicht wo lagers ist du hast
gar nicht was das ist max macht mal
irgendwo
ich musste glaube ich mal einen tipp
geben weil du ganz auf dem falschen trip
ist zwar du bist ein kanal wenn ich das
komme hat die services werden
das komme dies aber derzeit auch in der
ersten folge von war dabei aber ich bin
dann bin ich ja okay es geht weiter ok
ich wohne nicht in köln habe ich habe
ich blonde haar wird drechselt ich denke
ich und habe ich jetzt gerne bleiben
nein war nämlich gerade angerufen mit
wechselnden formen
nein das war eine frage natürlich eine
frage ja komm du hast du fragte was bin
ich alt bin ich alleine auf meinen kanal
passiert schon mal laura so da hab ich
jetzt gerade habe ich dann ist riese
schon mal draußen ist toni klose auch
schon mal raus war ich einer der
spielenden minecraft war justin ein wo
nicht in berlin oder hamburg naja honig
in berlin ist ja jetzt habe ich jetzt
über 2000 berlin mit über 8 dass ich
scheiße und operiert und klingt jetzt
einfach hat jungen in der
jugendwerkstatt
die zwischen 5.000 eine million
abonnenten vor in berlin habe erst mal
bunte haare sind sie allein auf einem
kanal bin ich nie
nein das mache ich auf meinem heutigen
kanal immer noch let's play videos oder
ja mein schild bezieht sich auf den
kanal der opfer waren dabei
nein und jahren tauschte nein ist der
canadier-zweier waren dabei war größer
als mein jetziger kanal
ich war doch mit gegen bar- oder bei die
karten eigen gleichzeitig den
entscheidenden tipp geben und dann könnt
ihr das zuerst raus du kennst wir so
sehr sehr gut persönlich und beauty
beauty videos männlich war wird nicht
das was man heute circa drei stunden
gebraucht
die ganze sache zu erwarten deswegen der
ernte jetzt mal zu hause dann könnt ihr
hier trieb noch eine folge was geht ab
checken von meinem projekt mit
unitymedia hier abonnieren und die
beiden in der beschreibung